[Music]
ancient Hidden Treasures are lurking
underneath the Las Vegas Valley Mary
Jane Valley as it took a trip out to a
new State Park opening in North Las
Vegas
take a step back in time and explore
history as Ice Age fossil state park
near Decatur and West Horse Drive is set
to officially open at the end of this
year right below the surface the
preserved remains of horses bison and
mammoths one big blast from the past I
don't have the words to express how
excited I am about finally getting this
place open to the public trustee Walter
panzero from the Helmsley charitable
trust along with the Nevada division of
state parks announcing a 3.5 million
dollar Grant to help complete the park
all nevadans all people in our portfolio
groups should have access to the outdoor
for health the property first obtained
by the Nevada edition of state parks
back in 1958 then declared a state park
in 2017 under Governor Brian Sandoval's
Explorer Nevada initiative that's one of
the things that Nevada state parks we
try to do is to make sure that we're
providing affordable recreational
opportunities for families the 315 acre
space has a visitor center featuring
featuring hustles and artifacts
interactive exhibits and a historical
film a space for temporary displays and
a gift shop this will allow families to
come out learn about stuff in a you know
more climate controlled setting then go
out on site and look at what's currently
out there